how the American people get their
information what the structure of
ownership is is an enormous interest to
all of us because it is the foundation
of our democracy read all about it
morning paper apparently our democracy
is yet again in peril this country
according to one concerned academic is
in the midst of a crisis that could
leave a dramatically diminished version
of democracy in its wake so what's
causing this looming crisis what's this
disaster that we must do everything in
our power to avert with the
proliferation of news on the internet
Americans aren't supporting their local
newspapers circulation and ad revenues
are way down well internet readership
where the news is likely to be free and
up-to-the-minute is way up technologies
change the game but for those who see a
connection between American democracy
and the demise of the newspaper business
it's time to get the government involved
to save the industry Maryland senator
Ben Cardin recently introduced the
newspaper revitalization act that would
provide news organizations a variety of
tax breaks and allow them to operate as
nonprofits newspaper revitalization act
offers an opportunity to save our local
papers on one point senator Cardin is
right in the past six months alone the
average daily circulation of us
newspapers declines 7% the Seattle
post-intelligencer the New York Sun the
Baltimore examiner all have closed their
doors while the New York Times Boston
Globe and Los Angeles Times are barely
clinging to life Cardin is hardly alone
in Congress Massachusetts Senator John
Kerry warns of the serious consequences
for our democracy if his hometown
newspaper The Boston Globe goes belly-up
and these politicians are readily joined
by a Cassandra chorus of lefty media
critics proposed a bold solution a
government intervention to save American
journalism and that means we're going to
have to turn to enlighten policy making
direct and indirect government subsidies
to give us the resources to do
journalist I mean that's Robert
McChesney co-founder of the activist
group Free Press and leading advocate of
government intervention to the news
business we asked free press senior
program director Craig Aaron what role
he sees for the government in propping
up the newspaper industry
what we need and where we think there's
a role for the for the government to
take an interest here is because we're
talking about a public good you know a
people need news and information to hold
their government and corporate leaders
accountable so when we look at what
should the government do to answer that
I think what they need to do is they
need to look at policies that are going
to encourage when these if these
companies go bankrupt if they collapse
if they're selling off how are we going
to encourage those papers to be put in
the hands of local communities
ironically just a few years ago the
founders of Free Press had a rather
different take on the news industry they
now want to preserve in 2005 the same
authors were lecturing about how
newspapers were destroying democracy
well they can't have it both ways either
newspapers of vital democracy or they're
undermining democracy Jack Sheaffer
media critic for the online magazine
slate takes a more sanguine view of the
current situation the news is incredibly
alive crackling and popping more people
are participating in making news
creating news reporting news than ever
before nor is it Schaeffer thinks the
media's job to act as a guardian of
democracy it's not our business to make
sure that I guess to promote voting or
it's not necessarily in our purview to
promote good government or to promote
clean elections those are sort of the
roles I think of political actors you
know what we do is report we observe and
we compete there there are a variety of
ways to to slice the news sausage
despite this proliferation of online
media outlets the rise of investigative
blogging in the huge variety of both
print and internet news sources Erin
thinks washington needs to create a
massive public works program to Train
journalists something akin to FDR's new
deal federal writers project we've got a
lot of talented experienced reporters I
think we should look at our they're
sensible ways to keep them on the beat
may be short a short term fund maybe
it's a job retraining maybe it's
investing in young people sort of an
AmeriCorps for journalism beyond the
question of how much these bailouts will
cost taxpayers it's difficult to imagine
reporters subsidized by the government
maintaining their journalistic
independent
that hallmark of the American press and
beyond that with such a bailout even be
successful in France which subsidize its
newspaper industry for decades the piles
of taxpayer cash hasn't stopped the
exodus of readers despite these
subsidies President Nicolas Sarkozy
recently offered up another 800 billion
dollars to bail out an industry that is
refused to adapt an industry that finds
it nearly impossible because of deeply
entrenched labor unions to rid itself of
ineffective employees in fact the French
government is now providing free
newspaper subscriptions to 18 year olds
to boost circulation now just imagine
this level of government involvement in
the United States what would nickels in
machesney both of whom have written
scathing denunciations of the media's
behavior in the run-up to the Iraq war
have said if this very same journalist
wrote the very same stories in 2002 but
we're reliant upon the Bush
administration for their survival I'm
suffering a kind of intellectual
whiplash that now all of a sudden left
wingers who despise the press and the
corporate media for so long all of a
sudden now think that oh there's
something there to redeem and save and
protect Washington can give them tax
breaks generous subsidies or as has been
the case with the auto industry take an
ownership stake in newspapers by bailing
them out with cash but none of this
changes the fact that the web has
creatively destroyed old models of both
reporting and transmitting the news so
we can keep printing an unprofitable
uninteresting and increasingly unread
physical newspaper with any combination
of government subsidies but as the
French found we can't force people to
read them unless we give them all free
subscriptions for reason TV I'm Michael
Moynihan